et
[Musique]
toutes les expéditions contre gégène ont
échoué les shadoks ont décidé de
l'amadouer en lui jouant de la musique
dans le cadre de la grande campagne
d'éducation de shadocks nous assistons
donc aujourd'hui à un tour de musique
jadot
[Musique]
oui
la musique shadoks comment le voyez
consistait en grande partie à faire du
bruit avec n'importe quoi car c'était un
des principes de base de la musique
shadoks pour une oreille bien exercer il
n'y a pas de bruit qui ne puisse être
entendue comme une musique et
réciproquement
le tout est une question d'exercice
c'était assez pénible est assez long
mais il fallait persévérer car c'était
un autre principe de base que la musique
shadoks
c'est en forgeant que l'on devient
musicien cette nouvelle expédition
indigènes puis donc ce que l'on pourrait
appeler une quête musicale et jade au
kavé niankoye évidemment tout un
matériel très moderne de guerre musicale
est totale
m
[Musique]
si j'ai réussi c'est à résister à tout
ça c'est que vraiment il n'y avait plus
rien à faire
[Musique]